welcome to this video playing eraser
double-oh-seven one of those Knicks were
you sort of instinct of you think I wear
this guy must be dangerous okay here in
the Kings Indian and maybe the exchanges
the the right way to go against the
razor keep it simple yeah Black has a
big big choice here can play all kinds
of moves rookie a group of 86 97 my day
6 all kinds of moves this is the
classical way to play it that's a very
solid reputation okay let's briefly
think about this mighty said mrs.
castles hmm I think Castle German
what did I confuse it Knight f6 to come
have an ID to as the move I usually play
but I thought castles would be okay as
well I'm really confused now there
should be three you can play Knight f6
and what am i doing then don't see a
movie after that there should be three
is not good take you form hmm but this
just looks weird okay as usual I spent a
huge amount of time for nothing g5 was
much more critical g5 and Knight f6 no
just this now is some quite comfortable
again he's got some problems to develop
okay rook doubling may be doubling him
yeah this is what I want this type of
endgame I control both files and have
the better minor piece at least in the
long run it might be the better piece
night my travel to d5 okay hmm I wonder
if I should try that even now maybe try
that now yrc too okay he will probably
go f5 hmm should I try to prevent it
with rock t6 let's let's try that
because g 6 is hanging came i can't even
go G for try to play against this idea
but the way they can also go here he
tells to me this is very boring line amp
you already worse so probably it wasn't
a bad choice ok 95 not effective
effective against strong players to we
rights me yeah whatever you say whatever
you say ok might have the bishop deform
okay let's see see threatening anything
along like to go to a five of course III
I can just take twice and f3 I play the
Jeep on I can just take him rookie 7 was
also good okay let's see just look here
just to take the upon yeah you wrote not
effective against strong players this
might be true but yeah it felt rather
effective against him though ok let's
see night see through yon is there some
some better line
97 would be nice to to get in but not
possible you came justjust do that oh it
can take c3 this i forgot i really
didn't want to allow that okay well it's
not it's not bad riddim g-form yeah this
is good because it's a temple and then I
take you for
yeah it's a very boring line you're
right but what can I say take its own
check
I'm always a bit confused if people
write stuff I mean why okay I'm down to
40 seconds so this is still something
that needs to be one check how to do it
problem where K is some advancing them
that's a bit tricky with 20-something
seconds hmm not sure that I'm winning
here i mortgaged not sure how to win
this maybe it's not possible don't see
you win nine seconds
check check now North no way to win it
unfortunately spend too much time let's
was being drawn quite a nice game but
then spend too much time and this isn't
so easy to win the this type of endgame
yeah probably it is easy to win but not
how I played it mm check but I'm sure
this is this is not so easy I don't
think it is so easy of course them
around here this deserve very easy
winning but yeah I should just take the
take the a pond and get it get it over
with this is this is easier and now just
just that let that the pawns run so this
is much much easier yeah here I probably
need to improve this rather early KF
five and maybe now push the pawns so
that I've blocked the King for the
moment but it's hmm I'm not sure if it's
really a win if he quickly returns this
two against term one
might only be a draw might only be it
wrong yeah I should have just taken a
seven earlier this is so much easier
okay thanks for watching